Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Imagine the following: we put an object on
a robot arm, and the input is a recorded video
of it.
And the output would be the digital geometry
and a material model for this object.
This geometry and material model we can plug
into a photorealistic light simulation program
to have a digital copy of our real-world object.
First, we have to be wary of the fact that
normally, solving such a problem sounds completely
hopeless.
We have three variables that we have to take
into consideration: the lighting in the room,
the geometry of the object, and the material
properties of the object.
If any two of the three variables is known,
the problem is relatively simple and there
are already existing works to address these
combinations.
For instance, if we create a studio lighting
setup and know the geometry of the object
as well, it is not that difficult to capture
the material properties.
Also, if the material properties and lighting
is known, there are methods to extract the
geometry of the objects.
However, this is a way more difficult formulation
of the problem, because out of the three variables,
not two, not one, but zero are known.
We don't have control over the lighting, the
material properties can be arbitrary, and
the geometry can also be anything.
Several very sensible assumptions are being
made, such as that our camera has to be stationary
and the rotation directions of the object
should be known, and some more of these are
discussed in the paper in detail.
All of them are quite sensible and they really
don't feel limiting.
The algorithm works the following way: in
the first step, we estimate the lighting and
leaning on this estimation, we build a rough
initial surface model.
And in the second step, using this surface
model, we see a bit clearer, and therefore
we can refine our initial guess for the lighting
and material model.
However, now that we know the lighting a bit
better, we can again, get back to the surface
reconstruction and improve our solution there.
This entire process happens iteratively, which
means, that first, we obtain a very rough
initial guess for the surface, and we constantly
refine this piece of surface to get closer
and closer to the final solution.
And now, feast your eyes on these incredible
results, and marvel at the fact that we know
next to nothing about the input, and the geometry
and material properties almost magically appear
on the screen.
This is an amazing piece of work, and lots
and lots of details and results are discussed
the paper, which is quite well written and
was a joy to read.
Make sure to have a look at it, the link is
available in the video description.
Also, thanks for all the kind comments, I've
experienced a recent influx of e-mails from
people all around the world expressing how
they are enjoying the series and many of them
telling their personal stories and their relation
to science, and how these new inventions are
being talked about over dinner with the family
and relatives.
It has been such a delight to read these messages.
Thank you!
And also, thanks for watching and for your
generous support, and I'll see you next time!